مع الاسبوع الاول من عرضه يتربى فيلم
افاتار في الجزء الثاني على راس الاعلى
ايرادا برقم قارب نصف مليار دولار امريكي
افاتار تصدر الجميع منافذ التذاكر عالميا
قبل عطله الكريسماس والعام الجديد وترشح
الفيلم بجزء الثاني ضمن قائمه افضل فيلم
درامي لهذا العام لينافس بقوه رغم عدم
طرحه للعرض التجاري بعد يطرح الجزء الثاني
من افاتار بعد مرور 13 عاما من طرح الجزء
الاول والذي حقق نجاحا كبيرا وتصدر شباك
الاردادات للسنوات سيما يمتد الجزء الثاني
لاكثر من ثلاث ساعات من العرض
الى لميس
نتعرف بالارقام على ميزانيه وارباح افاتار
بجزيئه الاول والثاني حتى الان
230 مليون دولار كانت ميزانيه انتاج فيلم
افاتار بالجزء الاول
250 مليون دولار كانت ميزانيه انتاج فيلم
افاتار في جزء الثاني مليارين و 800 مليون
دولار كانت ارباح الجزء الاول من فيلم
افاتار الذي انتج عام 2009 نصف مليار
دولار ايرادات الجزء الثاني من افاتار مع
الاسبوع الاول فقط من بدء العرض 13 عاما
المده التي استغرقها انتاج الجزء الثاني
من فيلم افاتار
95% هي النسبه التي وصل لها اكتمال انتاج
الجزء الثالث من فيلم افاتار
كويس
[موسيقى]
على كل من الرياضه
السينمائي اهلا بك يا طارق الجزء الثاني
من افاتار يتصدر الايرادات بنحو نصف مليار
دولار في الاسبوع الاول من عرضه سبب هذا
النجاح الجزء الثاني حدثنا اكثر
السبب الرئيسي انه الجمهور كان ينتظر بشكل
كبير جدا على مدى 13 عام
الجزء الثاني من افاتار خاصه بعد النجاح
الكبير لحقه غرفه عام 2009
وجزء اخر مرتبط بالنجاح مرتبط
بالطابع المرتبط به فتار بانه فيلم لا
ينضم الى مجموعه السوبر هيروز المنتشرها
او حتى تعليقات بعض الامريكيه انه ليس فيه
دينا
صورات همم ايضا اظن واحد من الاشياء
المرتبطه بنجاح مرتبطه ايضا بطبع القصه
الداخلي الفيلم خاصه يركز على موضوع
العائله بشكل كبير جدا متخلص بكثير مما
يتعلق بالجده والصبيئه السياسيه الموجوده
في السير من الامريكان
طيب طارق
اليوم عم نحكي عن 13 سنه يعني اذا في طفل
كان عمره عشر سنوات فاتوا الجزء الاول
اليوم هذا الطفل صار عمره 23 سنه هل يعني
انه يجب عليه انه يتابع كان الجزء الاول
ام لا من لم يتابع الجزء الاول لم يفوته
اي شيء فيستطيع ان يتابع الجزء الثاني
بسهوله
انا اظن انه هذا مرتبط
على سبيل المثال اللي ضرب مثلا 2 اللي كان
يعني يعتبر واحد من اهم الافلام في تاريخ
السنه همم ما كان مهم جدا للمشاهدين ان
يعرف قصه الجزء الاول اللي هي مرتبطه
بجذور بالموضوع مثلا على سبيل المثال لو
لو
شاهدت فيلم مثلا ايليا اللي اشتغل عليه
ايضا كاميرا الاول اللي كان مع سكرينه
فارس كان نفس الموضوع هو الفيلم الجمس عند
القدره يبدا السبت
لكن اللي اعتقد بشكل كبير جدا انه هذا
الجزء الثاني
سيدفع المشاهدين للعوده الاول
طيب طارق يعني في المرشح ضمن قائمه افضل
الافلام
على مدى التاريخ الدراميه هل هو سبب في
اخراجه هل في فكره الفيلم ام تعلق الجمهور
بافلام الخيال العلمي
في البدايه افاتار في الجزء الثاني اللي
هو طريقه
الترجمه يعني مرتبط اول شيء بانه في
استعراض بصري هائل جدا يعني
انا اظن جيمس كاميرون واحد من اهم
المخرجين فيما يتعلق بدفع اقصى الحدود
الموجوده في ما يتعلق
بالاشتغال على المؤثرات البصريه
والاستخدامات المؤثرات ال همم الكمبيوتر
والموازنه بين هذا الخل يقول السجاير
موجود في فيلم وفي نفس الوقت رابع التمثيل
وايضا جزء مرتبط بشكل كبير جدا بانه يتكي
على قصه يعني يمكن ان يكون الجمهور
الامريكي في المقام الاول
لكن لكن فيما يتعلق في القصه يعني دخلنا
منطقه على قضيه سنقول انه هناك يعني بعض
موجوده في القصه انه لا يقول شيء جديد عن
القصه الاولى انه في شيء يهدد هذا العالم
بالدوره والشعوب اللي موجوده فيه ال- اا
في الكوكب اه نعم بالحديث عن الجزء الاول
طارق في الجزء الاول اوكي في الجزء الاول
كان في رسائل عده مبطنه في فيلم افاتار
حتى ان كثيرا من شعوب الارض الذين تعرضوا
لاستعمار كان دول استعمرتهم او لاحتلال
اعتبروا بان شعب افاتار يمثلهم وانه يشبه
قصتهم في هذه الدنيا وفي الواقع اليوم
عندما نتحدث عن افاتار 2 الذي استغرق 13
عاما والسبب الرئيسي بسبب النص ما هي
الرسائل المبطنه بسببه اليوم
يعني الرسائل الاساسيه الموجوده في الفكره
القائمه على انه يعني هناك شعب يعيش في
سلام متصل مع الطبيعه بشكل مميز جدا ثم
بعد ذلك ياتي المحتله من الخارج وبدلا
يحاول ان يعني يزاحم هؤلاء بشكل سلمي في
الحصول على موارد الارض بدا يحاول ان يعني
يخرج هذا الشعب من مكانه ويدمر الحياه
اللي موجوده فقط يعني فكره قائمه فقط على
النص
والاستحواذ على كل ما ورد هذا الكوثر بس
يعني اذا تسمحي لي هذه يعني ليست المره
الاولى في السنه الامريكيه ولا السينما
الاوروبيه المثال لانها تركز على هذا
موجود في المكهانتس مثلا من ديزني هذا
موجود مثلا في الراس مع الذئاب
هذا موجود في افلام يعني انا اقصد انه
القصه موجوده لكن مدعومه بشكل كبير جدا
باستعراض بصري همم
شكرا جزيلا من الرياض طارق الخواجي الكاتب
والناقد سينمائي الف شكر شكرا جزيلا لك